bajo un sol de plomo en este campamento
Turco para sobrevivientes del terremoto
lleva a chingar a pesar de sus difíciles
condiciones de vida se mantiene fiel al
actual presidente receta gipeduana mi
mujer está discapacitada no tenemos
electricidad ni agua cita allí Perdón
gana las elecciones estos problemas se
solucionarán pero si no gana hay de esta
gente
sin embargo otros habitantes afectados
tienen un discurso muy diferente sobre
aduana y la respuesta de su gobierno a
la catástrofe
toda mi familia se ha ido todos
fallecieron Por qué no iba a enfadarme
con el gobierno ninguna maquinaria vino
a ayudar nada lo hizo
esta región del sur de Turquía de 9
millones de personas ha sido
tradicionalmente un bastión de aduana
pero con el terremoto las cosas podrían
cambiar esta persona sigue en el
hospital está herido y su madre está en
cuidados intensivos
este votante de aquí falleció
este funcionario Comparte el sentimiento
de abandono que expresan mucho
sobrevivientes y alerta sobre la
urgencia de la situación
no podemos estar preparados para las
elecciones en este entorno nosotros y
miles como nosotros no estamos
preparados en absoluto para las
elecciones se están celebrando
prematuramente
la primera vuelta de terminará si los
votantes harán rendir cuentas al
gobierno actual por considerarlo
responsable de las fallas en la
respuesta a la catástrofe en lo que
muchos afectados están de acuerdo es que
estos comicios no ocupan un lugar
prioritario siendo la supervivencia
diaria el problema más urgente